Hebert one this is Kim from the test
website comm and today we are in round
two of our coverage of the 2018 Tata
Steel tournament with 14 of the best
chess players in the world trying to
fight for the top spot we have two
competitors today why it's gonna be
played by audubon basket on the 25 year
old Indian Grandmaster if you're not too
familiar we haven't had too many games
of his that we've covered 2008 he was
the world under 16 champion 2009 he was
the Indian Champion and no machine on
did not play in that particular
tournament in 2016 he won the
challengers bracket in the Tata Steel
we're looking at the Masters bracket
right now but there are other
tournaments going on at the Tata Steel
so he was invited to play in the last
year's Tata Steel and got third place he
was half a point behind second place
Magnus Carlsen which is his opponent
today Magnus Carlsen needs no
introduction he is the world champion
and he'll be playing the black pieces
does extremely well in these tournaments
so looking to get back on track with a
win here since he did tie in the first
game with the white pieces so we'll get
started without him on with white pieces
pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6
Knight c3 Knight f6 so getting into the
four Knights game and then pawn to d4 so
this is the Scotch for Knights opening
what I like about this opening from
White's is it's fairly aggressive this
tends to go towards open positions both
sides can be extremely aggressive
playing against the world champion and
saying I welcome that let's try to play
an open aggressive game here I think is
a bold strategy the pawn takes the
Knights can recapture and then the
bishop comes down here to be four this
is much better than let's say if the
Knights were to take here on d4 and then
the Queen recaptures most of the time
black is gonna have a hard time taking
back the center of the board if we look
at some moves pawn to d6 probably the
best move trying to open up the door
work for these two bishops and also
defending the square here on e5 but then
Bishop to f4 white can castle on the
Queen side black doesn't have a ton of
pieces developed on board and you know
many times you'd bring your Bishop down
here to g4 to attack the Queen but the
Queen's are in the center attacking
Bishop to e7 doesn't really do too much
for your development beyond just getting
ready to castle on the King side but you
allow your opponent to really dominate
the center of the board if you don't
play pawn to d6 let's say it's more just
Bishop to e7 getting ready to castle on
the Kings side this is much worse you
can see the issue where the pawn needs
to be here in d6 pawn here to e5 forcing
the knight to move no real good options
has to come back here to g8 and then
Bishop to c4 White is off to the races
completely dominating this board state
so what it looks pretty innocent to just
take with your knight here you're gonna
exchange material definitely recommend
not taking that with your knight and
extend trying a few other options Magnus
Carlsen brings its Bishop down here to
b4 Madame bond plays Knight takes on a
c6 and then the pawn captures here on b7
and Magnus could really take both with
both of these pawns here from d7 or b7 I
do like that he chose to take with his
beep on because if pawn takes here you
could see an exchange right here and I
don't get the sense that Magnus across
him wants to give up his Queen already
he's already down one minor piece
they've exchanged the Knights early on
and while he could easily come away with
a victory if he plays the endgame
correctly it's much harder to get a
victory here this is more of a draw game
than if he's able to hold on to his
queen and get to some of those open
aggressive lines that we talked about
earlier so manas Carlsen looking to
fight his way to a victory hopefully at
least plays pawn takes here on a c6
Bishop to d3 getting ready to castle on
at the kingside pawn down here to d5
really trying to strike the center of
the board pawn takes and then castle on
the King side and this is one of those
other interesting points where Magnus
Carlsen looks at and he recognizes that
he
doesn't have to take the pawn right away
he can do an in-between move castle on
the kingside because yes the pawn can
take here but it's pretty difficult for
for white to have as good of a game as
he wants you know I'll go over a few
options and what they may look like the
main one would just be rook to e8
usually gonna be bringing your rooks to
the center of the board especially open
files where they can control on the
board
this is Czech and so you know what
options does white have here he's not
gonna bring his Queen in front he's not
gonna move his bishop because then you
could see some trading off and then the
Queen could come down here things can
get pretty pretty ugly so maybe you see
Bishop to e3 okay well after Bishop to
e3 then the bishop takes you see the
ponder he captured there's triple pawns
here on the C file and now Knight down
here to g4 threatening this bishop right
here this is completely fine for black
he's he's okay with this it's gonna be
easy for him to get back this material
that he's lost so maybe we come back and
say and instead of the rook to e8 what
if instead we see Bishop down here to g4
okay well this is it's hacking this
Queen maybe the Queen comes up here to
d2 and then rook to e8 and this is
forcing something a little bit different
the bishop can no longer come here to e3
and you force your opponent to play a
move sub-optimally like King to f1 can
no longer castle on the King side so
white decides yeah there's no reason for
me to take this pawn magnus carlsen
would be able to get back material
whenever he wanted to so takes the safer
route castles on the King side and then
magnus carlsen takes with this pawn here
on d5 Bishop to g5 getting the bishop
involved into the game completing a
development here pawn to c6 just
solidifying at this pawn chain here with
c6 and e5 Queen here to f3 so starting
to attack the center of the board here
with the Queen
cuz you're back here to d6 rook here to
e1 controlling this open file and then
rook to b8 says yeah if if no one's
going to the
Phin that this queenside the board I'm
gladly going to attack it with my rook
brings it to the semi-open foul here on
b8
and then pawn to b3 the move we all
expected to see very safe move from
white doesn't have to worry too much
about the Queen side of the board
Magnus Carlsen has not done though he
continues to attack pawn here to a5 pond
h3 says okay yeah I'll let you do your
thing on the Queen side the board all my
materials here on the King side so I'm
gonna start pushing on that pawn to h3
does stop the bishop coming down here to
g4 also if the knight wanted to come
down here g4 wouldn't do that right away
since it is being pinned down with his
bishop to the Queen but eventually could
always bring his knight down here to g4
so that's her pawn to h3 upon to age 6
and this is you know somewhat
interesting because Magnus Carlsen is
forcing his opponents to pretty much do
the exchange we're gonna be showing and
that's Bishop takes here on f6 Queen
takes the Queen takes and then the pawn
takes here on f6 so - Carlson has given
himself a double pawn structure here on
the F file with no connecting pawns so
definitely not good for Magnus Carlsen
but the thing he did gain is a bishop
pair always always valuable for Magnus
Carlsen he tends to always surprise his
opponent and do powerful things
especially in an open board state which
we have right now so if we look from a
t-bonds perspective how does he continue
he has the better pawn structure so if
he can get to an in game he should do
fairly well well here he wants to get
his not involved into the game right now
he doesn't have a lot of great moves for
it doesn't want to bring it over here to
a for the e-files know where you want
your knight you want to involve into the
center of the board but he can't bring
it here to d5 or efore so instead first
brings it to e - and he can maneuver
from here he could bring it over to the
King side of the board with king or
Knight here to g3 or if he wanted to
play Knight to d4 and really start to
attack this backward pawn on a c6 or
even started to attack on at the King
side of the board he could as well pawn
to d5 saying yeah totally see what you
could be doing here I'm gonna stop that
right away so instead we see a table on
play and
to g3 madness continues with rook to d8
a knight up here to f5 were just kind of
an annoying move for magnus carlsen to
have to deal with it attacks this pawn
right here on h6 which is hanging he
doesn't really want to have to commit
his king to something and then if he
does commit his king then he's just
gonna lose his bishop and then all of a
sudden he's back to where he was as far
as equal material both sides having a
bishop but now he has double pawns here
on that file that's not as good that's a
much better in game for Audubon so he
decides to go and bring his bishop back
here to f8 to protect this pawn and he
doesn't lose his bishop really the best
move he has here but Bishop to or Knight
to e7 is tough to deal with because he's
in he's going to end up losing a bishop
here this is Czech and so he could just
take this bishop here on c8 a so magnus
carlsen forced to just take here and
after the rook takes on e7 all of a
sudden white is in the better position
both sides have a light square Bishop on
board but pawn or white definitely has
the better pawn structures Magnus
Carlsen having four different sections
here you know pawn chains and the double
pawns here on the F file not ideal for
Magnus Carlsen Bishop here to e6 trying
to block in the rook can't really attack
it too much except with his rooks if the
King ever comes here he can always move
his rook to these dark squares
since black doesn't have a Knights or a
dark square Bishop not gonna be able to
attack those squares so it is fairly
safe even though it doesn't look like it
is trapped behind enemy lines here
rook it to d1 and the Magnus Carlsen
starts going on the attack says let's
just start blowing up the Queen side of
the board pawn to c4 Bishop down here to
e2 since was being attacked pawn to a4
and then the pawn recaptures Magnus
Carlsen right now I was just given up a
pawn he recognizes that although he's
down upon his opponent now has double
pawns on the a file and of all the files
that you don't want double pawns on the
a file and the H file
because they really have a hard time
being as productive as some as the
others we're in the center of the board
you can protect them a little easier
your pieces tend to want to be in the
center of the board anyway and so over
here it's gonna be easy pickins for
Magnus Carlsen if he wants to get that
material so right now I'm not too
worried about he's trying to be as
aggressive as possible
Bishop to f5 attacking this pond and
then Bishop to f3 and this is
interesting because we see white take
over 20 minutes for this movie it's who
main options he could have played Bishop
to f3 what he played but he could have
also played pawn to c3 which is
interesting does not give up this
material right here on c2 which he did
in the game from playing the bishop here
to f3 but instead you know it's just
kind of asking his opponent what do you
want to do here pawn to d4 okay we could
see an exchange with the bishop taking
here on c4 and then if the pawn wants to
take on c3 we see some exchange I think
this is fine form White's perspective
this isn't easy to find because he
doesn't have too much time on the clock
white spend a lot of time throughout
this entire game for all of his moves
making sure that they all been precise
Magnus Carlsen on the other hand has
been pretty quick with all of his moves
but they at the end of the day after 20
minutes
Bishop to f3 is the move now pawn down
here to a d4 pawn up here to a5 and then
the bishop takes on c2 as we talked
about Magnus Collins not even too
worried about this pawn up here on a5
the rook is being attacked so the route
comes here to c1 attacking the bishop
and then rook down here to be 1 adds
maximum pressure to his opponents really
forcing his opponent to have an exchange
here you can't take the bishop because
this rook is being pinned down to the
king that would be an illegal move so
decides really doesn't have an option
let's go ahead and take that rook Bishop
takes here attacking this pawn looking
to gobble up some material here rook to
a c7 but then pawn pushing forward to c3
so black has to pass pawns that are
connected which is the best type of pass
pawn to have having a buddy there to
protect you and you don't have to worry
about your rooks or bishops or anything
protect
but black does have a rook behind
helping push these pawns if he ever
needs to white he does have his own past
pawn here but it doesn't have his rook
behind that pushing forward he's a
little bit more difficult the only thing
he does have is the square where you
would promote to here on a eight he does
have a lights where a bishop bad thing
about that is his opponent also has a
light square bishop so he can stop the
square here on a eight from blacks
perspective Bishop down here to a d1
rook to a eight attacking of that pawn
rook coming down here to c5 defending
that pond gobbling up this material
right here so for Magnus Carlsen side he
has the pawn advantage now while he does
have a two pawns here on the F file
these two pawns in the Sooner board are
just so difficult for white to deal with
right now Bishop here to see - you know
as far as what other options he had
could try to activate his his King but
not a lot of great options here Bishop
here to see - Bishop to e6 after gobbled
up this material once to get his Bishop
back to the center of the board
controlling things so we can move
anywhere he needs to and you know back
here on a2 really couldn't do that and
so that's why he brings it back any
other move is just not great you don't
want to bring it here to b3 a c4 or d5
your opponent would just take those
automatically so B Bishop to e6 is the
go-to move here King to f1 rook over
here to c8 says let's go an exchange on
board this is gonna be fine with me
white doesn't have too many options
decides to go ahead and exchange on
board and you can see this stops the
pawn coming here to a6 the bishop could
even just come down here to a6 and stop
the push right here eventually Magnus
crossing can get his King involved into
the board pushing these pawns it's gonna
be so difficult there's so many threats
that white has to deal with King here to
e2 bishop down here a six check and then
King to f3 is the last move now you know
it's tough for white just doesn't have
enough time left in the game only has a
few minutes left just over 2 minutes
left in the game so can't really think
about the best move Magnus Carlsen has
over
forty-two minutes left on his clock so
while he's trying to go fairly fast at
the end of this game which is nice he
had a he has the advantage right here
and he doesn't want to give his opponent
even time to think while Magnus Carlsen
has his time going so right here we do
see King to f3 and then pawn to d3 is
the last move and in this particular
spot we see a de bon resigned there's no
way to really stop the threats at Magnus
Carlsen had even if white were to play
something else doesn't have to play King
to f3 maybe it was King to e1 it's still
going to be very very difficult to hold
on to here but in the game after we see
King to f3 pawn to d3 the game's over
people always ask well how could this
game continue why it's really gonna have
to take here if he doesn't blacks gonna
have a very very easy promotion but if
the bishop takes bishop takes right here
King over here to e3 so there's not a
the fastest promotion ever but if we see
the bishop come back here to a 6 then
this stops a lot of the squares that the
king can go to because of the light
square bishop can't come to e 2 or D 3
and this pawn here on c3 stops the King
from coming down here to d2 so anytime
the King were to move somewhere else
they'll say King to e4 if he just moves
up one square 4 anywhere all of a sudden
this pawns gonna push forward and that's
going to be a game over promoting to the
Queen
so madness Karl says all the time in the
world to get his King involved into the
action even if white starts to push
forward doesn't matter because the King
cannot come and add any value to that
attack so Magnus Carlsen would have
easily won this game so all in all
congratulations to Magnus cross and ease
half a point behind the lead someone
already has two wins of the first two
games so manage Carlsen will be looking
to continue his hot streak from audubon
basket on a great game from him you know
it's always tough playing against Magnus
Carlsen
but I thought he played extremely well
didn't play scared at all played some
aggressive openings and at the end of
the day just
made some small errors at the end magnus
carlsen just so-so strong in these open
games getting into the late tactical
parts of chess magnus carlsen he's the
best so thank you guys for watching a
very exciting chess game today I'm gonna
have coverage of every round in the
tournament there will be 12 rounds with
I think a break every few days maybe
four or five days and they take a break
and then do four or five days again so
we'll have coverage for the next few
days for sure thanks for watching I'll
see you guys in the next video